come on like a big bed
we gonna
the date has begun how about you
introduce yourselves
i was just working on that button
my name's evan my name is hannah hannah
doesn't wash her bed sheets very often
it's kind of off topic
are we talking like two weeks the
buttons out here blocking off the top
yeah uh evan actually has doo-doo stains
on them right now doo-doo brown that's
nasty how do you even get that detail
they do
on the sheet or on you do the pre-screen
it's like how often do you clean your
sheets and the [ __ ] is like never
maybe like a month
yeah i mean and how frequently do you
wash your veggies
i feel like it's every two weeks i
thought that was kind of long but to
each
okay
my guy
you took it now
she took a nail because she don't wash
her sheet and her booty dirty
you took it out because she told you
that her booty's dirty and you're like
i'm going in
and you're gay so like i don't even know
why you even maybe he's not
sorry evan hannah why did you reject him
i just like
didn't feel attracted to him i guess i
just don't like the fact that he washes
his sheets every two weeks i don't know
something about his clean look
i wonder how he feels about pets
specifically bed bugs jesus i love your
hair
i like your eyeliner thank you
what do you like to do i like to place
volleyball oh yeah i play volleyball too
really yeah i played in high school um i
was in the back where i was a hitter is
volleyball a gay sport
yes the spandex the spandex that's what
got us
that question felt very inappropriate
it's volleyball
sport
gays were hispanics i guess
but think about it
well okay listen france gay
by definition but i guess gay
[ __ ] in paris
on bicycles gay
think about it
think about it
and how you write and how you write it
how they ride on the bike they're not
they're like this right they're like
this right and they ride right or like
this i don't know one of the two right
they're like this
right like this what do they see in
front of them
butts game
i mean it sounded dumb at first
but that [ __ ] game
you mad
i'm just
i was just joking you you wilding
uh do you all know that they inject
themselves
yeah of course where do they inject
themselves
in their legs
but
gay
okay you got issues am i lying you got
issues
how am i lying how does that not get
inject your butt no
you're literally penetrating your ass
[Applause]
[Music]
are you attracted to each other
yeah i think you're cute
[Music]
i think you're like hot thank you what
are you two looking for in a partner
like friend first and like someone you
can lean on like definitely more like
emotional
yeah like side of things first yeah no i
totally agree i'm actually a sex worker
so like
usually that's what happens
that's what happened let's see if women
are gonna behave toxically like men do
these they're not supposed to i wanted
to like just have sex with someone i
could but i want like
get it get it
i just want to appreciate that's usually
why so many people got mad oh abby you
[ __ ] [ __ ] misogynist why are you
acting like sex workers hey listen
i just said that most dudes don't want
to date him turns out
lesbians either most girls don't want to
date him either
it's hard it's really hard for um
sw to uh
to
to find someone very hard even if they
connect that first and [ __ ] that really
put off a lot of people it's a lonely
[ __ ] world
hey listen it's not even the shame or
nothing i'm just telling you it is what
it is sorry sapphire it's okay
[Laughter]
i would have limited for that laugh that
[ __ ] uh
i smoke weed
[Applause]
[Music]
listen i like sea life i like dolphins
not in the bedroom
no thank you that laughed at you know
when you
[Music]
before your card starts
why'd you do that
it kind of caught me off guard that she
was a sex worker
and she kind of like intimidated me
how are we going so
when was the last time you two had sex
[Music]
a week ago
about it we gotta go
balding chin strap getting eliminated
yeah patrick are you polly i am yes
oh yes okay have you like been in a
polyamorous relationship before i uh
this is my first
you guys are catching owls by that
person how you doing i'm good how are
you good i love your eyeliner thank you
i love your makeup too thank you green
favorite color it's my favorite it's my
favorite color they both look like they
walked into a thrift shop naked and just
we're only allowed to take three items
now you know who was the owner of the
thrift shop
hassan [ __ ]
okay okay all right listen i don't know
you just look at these women and if you
have to guess their political
affiliation you're like socialist right
yeah yeah
[Applause]
you both have so much in common i mean
yes green and graphic design my two
personality traits right here
sorry hannah this shows how fake
[ __ ] are oh my god yes yes oh
yeah
they both went for this no yes
absolutely green
there could only be one in a thrift shop
bye [ __ ] sorry hannah smith
you're so nice um loved meeting you
you're amazing no no no bye bye bye bye
bye
bye bye bye
yes nsync or is that the other thing
seven up there
uh 11 heaven what the [ __ ] the name of
the group
what is it i was in thick back street
backstreet boys my bad it wasn't bad
enough
what's the what's the group with all the
uk people uh was that uh s club seven
seven eight
seven up 7-eleven
hey man
i'm so straight i don't even know my boy
bands
[Laughter]
hey s club seven seven up it kind of
makes sense oh get that s club
eleven gonna show
[Applause]
no you you
remember that [ __ ] that's a big game
what was gay you don't know any boys man
but you know that song that song is fire
that sounds fire
yeah yeah and they have some hot girls
in there too that makes me extra strict
there's some hot girls in there don't
even cat
no they can't put put on one in the
comments if you think about yo listen
i'll put a picture of the s club tell me
the ladies
yeah but you know the song we gonna show
you how listen
[Music]
there is
why are you why are you no but there is
don't act like i'm crazy we all had
radio we all had to hear it don't
pretend like you did it why are you
acting brand new like you're right
i'll be good bro okay then good they're
sticking with me
come on we know what it is
[ __ ]
everybody now come on we know what it is
you wasn't doing that [ __ ] on halloween
everybody cause you always deny it
that's the thing and now i don't do that
all of a sudden you're like ass clap
you're like
the song gotta come on
that's what my big you know that's wrong
my daddy's come out all right let's go
you're bad [ __ ] go bad [ __ ] go bad
[ __ ] go bad [ __ ] that's my birthday
good bad [ __ ] go bad [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] hey somebody somebody's gonna clip
this and be like this is the gayest [ __ ]
i've ever seen and you know what let me
just do an honorary pause
with a little gravitas pause just to
come back
oh [ __ ] you had so much in common i know
i just wasn't feeling the spark and then
also if i'm being honest uh some of the
people before were just like she buzzed
them out really fast and i don't know
about that vibe i don't know
do you think i'm cute i mean yeah i mean
my gender i see myself as like a green
orb in my mind mental health
mental health that's almost
[Laughter]
no but not now that was you all right
all right here we go hey
hello heelys
yeah yeah
uh what's your name emil emil nice i'm
pie pie mm-hmm magic
handshake yeah nice to meet you what are
healey is are you right
now look i don't judge people
do whatever you want to do you want to
come and look like a joker that's cool
and me i don't even cut my hair i just
my [ __ ] you need a haircut
oh no you're not the one i know i know
no no no no no no no
no no this is why i say that that's why
i say that i cut my hair with the butter
knife yeah i know you're not the one
when i see another person who cuts their
hair with a butter knife
i got to be like you're not you're not
ready for this do you wanna find
something no you're not the one
you're not the one what do you mean
you're not the one what you don't want
to come up to people and be like
no bro because i know i'm in a glass
house i'm good oh no no no
no
he's not you you can't be like ah
no hold up i can and i did what you
gonna tell me
i live in my glass house throw a rock
[ __ ] break the glass i don't give a
[ __ ] you want me to throw a rock yeah
i'll be in my glass house
and i know
so throw the rocks at me i'm still
throwing rocks palestine
yeah i know we gonna lose we still learn
rockets i don't give a [ __ ]
rockets rocks
you know rocks are not you can't get a
rocket without a rock yes you can
rock kids
you can't get a rocket without a rock
the knowledge has entered ukrainian you
have discovered the the the the the
invention of a poetry
we are going to continue
let us proceed bun doesn't know anything
okay yeah you want to take this one i
mean you're wearing that yeah you're
right uh healies are shoes that have um
wheels
in them
so would you consider yourself a skater
i consider myself an x-skate is it
because the wheels aren't there it's cuz
what oh on the heelys right now oh yeah
you know what
you can't i wasn't saying that oh my god
yeah i didn't like that
only when i light up red okay they're
american psycho this [ __ ] right here
how do you call that when a villain
becomes a villain and that's their story
original story that's a that's a villain
origin that's hilly boy's origin story
what are you talking about this man's
got his ar-15 in his backpack there's no
origin story true this is about to go
down
somebody check on the employees that
took us
oh this is awkward oh no yeah wow wow
this is their face
how you saw that right yeah that's what
like the nerd [ __ ] shows up in your
class with like gloves and a backpack
and you're like man i like nerd [ __ ] too
when you go to when you go to the first
screen view of um batman and you see
someone with orange
hair you're like hey you want to be
friends
do you remember that time where i
decided i'd never bully you
um this is so cringe
now we both want to hit the button
button
i mean i was vibing until you wanted to
make me leave so oh [ __ ] um what are you
looking for in a partner let's try and
save this yeah yeah no yeah um
basically i'm looking for a partner who
understands kiwis
i thought he just said basically i'm
looking for it not you but he's he
followed us
he went differently
someone who understands healy's
this is why i say [ __ ] the moment this
[ __ ] turn red you getting smacked the
[ __ ] it's a race i want to see the end
of this race this eraser who do you
think winning healy's or avatar i mean
he's going to roll to the button
hey listen if i have to bet on the
reflexes of a man or a woman
a woman
i do is what i'm saying
yes
i was not making fun of you for the
healies
do you like the cure
yes
i hope you're still alive
what happened i have to look up the cure
are you under the cure
they look like a band that represents
how he feels on the inside yes
dead
yes
hey hey listen bro listen you don't have
to walk away you just have to roll out
[ __ ]
[Music]
lunar chris has to be one of the most
underrated [ __ ] but the thing
is he's got one of the gayest bars so
that always
bangkok in bangkok i can't stop i turn
around hit the same spot i think not i'm
the thriller in manila schlong in hong
kong pimped him like bishop magic dong
wong
now the real question is as gay as that
verse is why do i know it by heart
pause
[Laughter]
we don't say bars over here you say
pause i hope they're not talking [ __ ]
about me back yeah you've been here for
a minute a little bit yeah oh hi i'm
leah leah yeah and pie okay
nice to meet you leah is kind of famous
on tick tock
tell me tell me about your how many how
many followers not that many not that
many just like 135 000.
not that many it's really not
what do you make what do you do on
tick-tock
uh
is it cringy
like thirst traps i guess
titties
lots and lots of titties
well i guess it's like a high at a low
sometimes i just want to like stay in
take a nap together i love like somebody
who could take a nap with me yes yeah
it's so sweet i love that so much
i get why you've been here so long
you're very likable oh my god thank you
yeah it sounds like the two of you
really compliment each other well i was
gonna say i think you're super cool so i
think you're cool too
where would you take pie on the second
date how do girls compliment each other
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
no you no you no you no you no you no
you no you i could freaking kill you no
you know you you're so stuffy i'm gonna
hug you till you die [ __ ]
you know you know you oh my god oh my
god that's how
[Laughter]
[Music]